das bett von blaues weg hat die instant
abgebaut die betten junge junge junge
junge dass es wahrscheinlich der
ultimative 6
servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge hacker schon heute mit
dem gast dem adrian agiler und wie immer
stellen wir euch heute die besten hacker
der letzten woche vor wie immer gilt
wenn ihr coole witzige hacker gefunden
hatten die betonung darauf dass sie
wirklich witzig sind aber wenn irgendwas
richtig krasses gesehen habe merkels
aufgenommen habt dann schickt mir
unbedingt auf youtube als private
nachricht also den link des umgerüsteten
youtube-videos und dann habt ihr gute
chancen auch in die nächste show rein zu
kommen so weit so gut wir fangen haben
mit der ersten sendung
diese anwendung stammt von chalki 3d und
er nennt das video hätte auch kein leben
etwas in dem zwei edition als 1000
seiten heute zwei gestalten wo ich meine
schauen wir uns mal kurz dieses bild an
dass sie ja schon ein bisschen suspekt
aus darum
wahrscheinlich ist es leidet ja alles
klar wahrscheinlich hat er 37 der welt
wie macht man das
vor dem war kommt lola lola leihski
laura viel mit der picke zweck lockt
junge
dieser moment aber so ein bisschen vom
weg abkommt und von der luft steht das
ist eine gute taktik also wenn man sich
entscheiden zu hacken
ziemlich gute taktik einfach sich neben
den weg zu stellen so wie er gerade eben
gelb hatte da wohl noch ein bett er ist
gestorben
wer das spiel verlassen erst geliefert
dann sein mate ist ein team als ist ein
hacker team eskaliert er stellt hierzu
stellt sich neben den weg gilt die leute
heute mal kurzer flashback zu dieser
stelle einfach herunter und bleibt in
der luft junge mann so das was weit von
dieser einsendung wir springt zur
nächsten okay leute die nächste 1
sendung stammt von 6000 hektar
einsendungen die einfach hacker show
keine ahnung was dann passiert wir
gucken mal rein nächste quali auf jeden
fall
fsg ist es okay wir gerade
wahrscheinlich alles klar kalauer des
todes ist die institute auf ihr herzen
alters keine proben oder spitex slow
down noch jungen alters was soll man
dagegen solche hacker überhaupt dass
keine chance hat nichts machen mehr geht
einfach insel hinterher
ok jetzt ja okay die fertige die
verbinden es jetzt gegen den hacker das
ist gut
natürlich die kinder raus erholt und der
henker gestört sehr schön so wir schauen
noch mal rein man will einfach nur sg
auf halb spielen passiert im moment
kennt ich kenne ihn nicht aber dann
einfach bock ob der typ für den berg und
fliegt instant los auf einen zu
schillers todes man fällt runter wie
keine chance mega viel schaden bekommen
und dann läuft er ein mit slow dann
hinterher springt einfach mit dem bogen
in der hand oder das war einfach ins and
down sehr bitte nicht so leute die
nächste 1 sendung stammt von klee fox hd
also clf weeks wodurch hd und eher
nettes video einfach wieder alles klar
war sehr gut an
ewig viele spectator und wir schon
finden wieder im bett was frei hacker
schon wieder aller macht jemand nicht
schlecht dass ich die beste taktik weil
diese ja nicht so mobil ist kein fleisch
sondern gleich leute wer will eigentlich
nicht gleiten in dieser runde junge
watch von ihr wird zeitgleich von zwei
kleider attackiert leute das war's schon
leute in the sky die anschreiben ist es
wirklich ein ding mal die kommentare
leute ist es wirklich ein gegen das man
wird mit alan joyce carol oates
reinschreiben wenn sie welche hacker
sehen
stellt euch vor ihr wollt es nur etwas
spielen da kommt zwar glide hacker zu
euch rüber geflogen
bitte allen so dass die nächste 1
sendung stammt von porno und er schreibt
aggressiver bett muss spiele hat okay
wir sehen hier schon mal dem hacker
seine base dieses bisschen abgeschnitten
wird aber hier steht dem hacker seine
basecap
das ist nicht die pace des hackers oder
des hackers pace aber nicht dem hacker
seine pace deutschland aus nicht alles
klar
durch mal wieder ein bisschen schaden
beim abheben
nice klartext also gewissen runter
gegangen wo jetzt wieder sagt eiskalter
rasiert einfach die ganze runde junge er
fliegt von gegner zu gegner alles klar
wie der killer junge das ist okay und
weiß es nicht ob das bett ab
yao machen etwa angeflogen
sieht irgendwie anders aus so aus als
würde durch die wand laufen so leute
hier seht ist nochmal da kriegt er
irgendwie schaden geht durch die wand
durch also steckt in der wand
wahrscheinlich hätte auch noch face und
nokia wie das heißt dass amazon hektar
notwendig ist auf jeden fall kommt hier
so er kriegt schaden auf einmal zack
bumm die runde ist vorbei und das andere
team hat gewonnen der hecke wurde
verdichtet gut gepackt
guck mal hier schwarz hat noch ein bett
schwarzen brett und auf einmal schwarz
oder vernichtet neben moment mal
moment mal achte mal draufhielt
schwarzen brett dann geht er kurz an die
wand dran auf ein neues bett werke wie
krass das ist achtet robbie schlägt in
schwarze runter schaut recht schwarzer
noch ein bett und jetzt auf einmal
schwarz kein bett mehr
er hat eiskalt durch die wand das bett
abgebaut
deswegen sei das so komisch aus diesen
instant gestorben
so hat jetzt schaut mal rechts auf die
auf das scoreboard schon mal recht auf
zack auf einmal ist es bett von orange
weg hat einfach nur kurz da rein
geschaut es schaut kurz zum bett und
baut das bett dann instant durch die
wand durch ab und jetzt fliegt darüber
zu welchem zu blau passt mal auf das
bett ist instant wieder weg warte also
als schaut man halt drauf er baut nichts
abschaut rechts aufs scoreboard und sagt
das bett von blau ist weg er fliegt
einfach nur hin und hat die instant
abgebaut die betten jungen junge junge
junge das ist wahrscheinlich der
ultimative wieseck pass auf jetzt geht
es ist schwarz rechts drauf statt rechts
rauf von 8 auf den spieler so rechts
auch unten sie dahin
er guckt kurz an die wand und auf einmal
ist weg alter schwede
das ist krass er baut einfach die blöcke
durch die wand durch ab wenn es mal die
hacks mitzählen
wer durch die wände durchgehen kann also
hat definitiv geleitet kilauea er hat
x-ray wahrscheinlich wenn er die betten
direkt anvisieren kann dann hat er noch
irgendwo mysteriösen heck mit dem man am
besten durch wände abbauen kann
ihr wisst wahrscheinlich wieder heck
heißt also wie heißt dieser hack mit dem
man betten durch wände durch abbauen
kann und er hat vielleicht noch no clip
oder face weil er irgendwie durch die
wand hier gerade durch geht sucht heute
das wasser weit von dieser folge hacker
steckt den adrian updates und der
beschreibung verlinkt eisdiele auf
youtube das war sowohl von mir
bis zum nächsten mal haut rein macht es
gut und ciao